we got hit by multiple IEDs I was hit by
one I was riding in the back of the
truck ended up getting hit when I was
just having to take my seat belt off and
reach over cross the Gunners platform to
grab a bottle of water when we got hit
and uh it really just went so fast at
that point and then it just slowed down
and it was just like everything just
kind of stopped when the blast hit I was
throwing up and hit my head on the roof
of the truck and I my way up I seen my
Gunners legs going out of the tert you
know you come back and you just don't
feel the same it's almost like I just
miss it I don't know I haven't figured
out how to put it to the side and just
be a normal civilian you know I like to
think that my deployment was worth it
you know I like we all like to think
that we made a difference
I'm proud every day of that uniform
Veterans Day to me is a day to remember
all those who have served and just to
honor them you know in the things that
they've done and things that they've
accomplished to give us a better future
you want to show your support or find
out how to show your support
just look up an organization set that
help veterans coming back maybe your
church or organization that sends care
packages out there because I mean when
we got out there we didn't have anything
I mean it would have been nice to have
some baby wipes you know or you know
just stupid little things you know
though those are the things that you get
home at the end of the day and you just
happen to get a care package from the
local church you know and hey there's
Kit Kat in there
any memories for three months straight
and haven't had anything and yeah I got
a KitKat you know that's cool you know
boots a little bit of around you know
that little bit of support says hey what
we're doing is appreciated